nearly a month after the third largest
jackpot in US history we finally know
the identity of the Wisconsin man who
became an overnight multi-millionaire
just think about that for a second
you're 24 years old your name is Manuel
Franco you claim the 768 million dollar
Powerball prize in Madison yesterday
go you Manuel Franco he said his biggest
financial goal before winning was
getting $1,000 in his bank account Wow
Don Dahler shows us how Franco was
feeling in his words
weirdly lucky when he bought those
tickets I honestly felt so lucky that I
did look at at the camera and I really
wanted the wink at it because I just had
that lucky feeling it Manuel Franco
didn't watch the Powerball drawing he
checked his ten dollars worth of tickets
online after work the next night when he
heard the winner was sold in Wisconsin
Franco said he was happy when his third
ticket won him four dollars but he
nearly missed the big one it was stuck
to the back of another my heart starts
to the pump and I'm not in at that
moment I'm like no no freakin way you
know I screamed for about five or ten
minutes my neighbors didn't hear Franco
says he actually went to work the next
day I was sweating so much that I'm sure
that everyone at work noticed but and I
really wanted to say something that
anybody there and I knew that it was a
bad decision and I pretty much never
showed up for work again his odds of
matching all six numbers were one in 292
point 2 million now after taking the
lump sum he'll have 326 million dollars
in his bank account for CBS this morning
Don Dahler New York now I think Manny's
Manuel Franco's story is very
interesting because he wouldn't say what
he does for a living I was very curious
about that he went to work the next day
but he was sweating so much as he said
he didn't go back again and he has a
girlfriend had a girlfriend I don't know
what their relationship is because they
both bought tickets together but he said
that winning ticket didn't have anything
to do with the tickets that we bought
together we might be feeling some kind
of way
another girlfriend I think he's about to
have many more new friends he was so
right John